pourquoi tu as besoin d'introduire pour
un coffre fort qu'est-ce qui vient
récupérer dans ce coffre-fort ya une
pierre est-ce que c'est comme coffre
fort un france jaeger j'ai un blanc
c'est un blanc formidable
ingénieux épatant le plus génial de tous
les plans qu'on n'ait jamais eu
l'occasion de mettre à l'essai
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit à bouche
les gratte ciel de drogue en plein coeur
de stockholm ce gros bonhomme qui
restent plantés sur toi c'est moi ou
quoi évidemment chacun de ces cinq
immeubles mesure 72 mètres de haut à
l'exception du troisième qui s'appelle
l'immeuble cool j'aime ici deux fois
plus grand que les autres c'est là tout
le temps pas que se trouve enfermé le
crif de la carélie la lampe torche tu
préfères mais est-ce que tu la veux je
vais pas très lumineuse alors ça me
paraît évidemment
[Musique]
j'y crois pas qu'elle soit c'est une
casse du siècle
je sais pas comment tu fais ça
mais j'imagine que c'est dans ma nature
et j'ai toujours l'idée date
[Musique]